[Musique]
salut à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur rt france pour la grande interview
place à une série d'entretiens pour
analyser l'expulsion de novak djokovic
d'australie en janvier dernier le serbe
joueur de tennis numéro un mondial
sanctionnée pour ne pas avoir fourni de
preuves de vaccination anti qu'ovide
dans un pays pourtant très à cheval sur
les règles sanitaires plusieurs semaines
après le joko gheit donc on accueille
sur ce plateau alexis trou de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes géopolitologue
spécialiste des balkans et auteur
notamment de l' ouvrage
géopolitique de la serbie aux éditions
ellipses plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines même après l'open d'australie
finalement remporté par rafael nadal
dans quel état d'esprit sont les serbes
les serbes sont très sereins et
notamment noah djokovic pourquoi parce
que pour lui c'est une bataille qui va
au delà de
du problème de l'oxydation il se place
il faut savoir que c'est quelqu'un qui
vient du kosovo qui se souvient très
bien des bombardements de l'otan sur la
serbie et le kosovo en 99 et donc pour
lui c'est la bataille du canda liberté
contre le camp de pression vous avez dit
qu'il était
bon qui a été expulsé d'australie mais
il faut rappeler quand même aux
téléspectateurs le déroulement des faits
quand ils arrivent en australie le 13
janvier 2022 il a ses papiers en règle 1
qu'il a eue auprès de la fédération de
tennis australienne et du consul
australien et c'est durant son voyage en
avion que les australiens ont changé de
règles est arrivé en australie la suite
on la connaît pendant deux semaines il
se retrouve dans une sorte de prison
pour non respect des règles alors qu'il
avait respecté les règles c'est une
affaire sportive mais c'est une affaire
politique est également vous avez dit
qu'il se bat pour la liberté novak
djokovic on le connaît peu politiquement
parlant qui est il exactement alors si
vous voulez politiquement il n'a jamais
pris une avis n'a pas de prétention
politique en serbie ou ailleurs mais si
oui il a toujours été depuis le début
contre
mais les contraintes liées partout dans
le monde d'ailleurs locaux vides et donc
là c'est bon exemple il est prêt si vous
voulez a sacrifié parce que pour lui
l'open d'australie c'était l'occasion
pour lui d'avoir un 10e titre de devenir
un des plus grands joueurs sinon le plus
grand joueur de tennis de l'histoire
mais il a préféré se sacrifier un titre
du grand chelem voilà voilà 25 ans
j'avais déjà ce ces greffiers et ne pas
être numéro 1 mondiale est peut-être
être dépassé par nadal ou d'autres
rapports au grand chelem pour pouvoir
être du côté des gens qui disent qu'il
faut en terminer avec les contraintes il
faut comprendre que pour les serbes
quand pour djokovic qui est issu du
cochonnet toshi la bataille du kosovo
c'est quoi en 13 189 c'est une bataille
où finalement les serbes se sacrifie et
choisissent les voix céleste plutôt que
les voies terrestres et donc accepte la
victoire des troupes ottomanes contre
les serbes port en serbie c'est une
victoire c'est à dire qu'on a gardé son
identité et garder sa liberté
en se sacrifiant et donc djokovic place
vraiment dans ce combat là il l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises et c'est pour ça
qu'il est depuis très serein
il est retourné au kosovo
à son retour d'australie il a fait le
tour des monastères il est actuellement
en pèlerinage dans le monastère le plus
important pour les serbes qui ont un
stère d'osterode monténégro et l'envoyer
il est vraiment du côté c'est une sorte
de pratiquement de sacrifice de la place
de numéro un mondial pour défendre les
idéaux de liberté qui doit être ceux de
tout homme la liberté individuelle la
liberté de choix choisir si je veux tel
vaccin ou un autre choisir de ne pas
être vaccinées ou non etc le président
aleksandar vucic a dénoncé une chasse
aux sorcières contre une personne mais
contre un pays également comme si
l'homme donc aux 20 titres du grand
chelem était devenu un martyr si ça
avait été qu il n aime pas paix ou ou
zidane
est ce que manuel mag on serait montés
au front comme l'a fait
comme vous dites c'est vrai que non pas
du tout c'est pas du tout la même
configuration il faut savoir que la
petite service est un pays de sept
millions d'habitants qui renaît de ses
cendres après plusieurs guerres d 1,90
seulement depuis 2006 donc c'est un pays
neuf sur l'échiquier mondial gucci che
videmment joue une carte politique très
fort parce qu'il sait très bien que
djokovic est le meilleur diplomates de
la serbie dans le monde et donc c'est
pour ça qu'il a soutenu mais à mon avis
derrière ça il ya vraiment beaucoup plus
que l'aspect politique aspect vraiment
culturelle identitaire c'est à dire 7
serbie qui s'est senti agressé et des
serbes en tout cas vous avez vu les
images en australie ces gens qui
dansaient les rondes folklorique qu'on
appelle le col devant le
voilà on voit l'image devant le s'était
justement pour soutenir djokovic
représentant liberté et représentant
quelqu'un qui défend leurs intérêts
culturels et en tant que qu'existe ans
partout à travers le monde juste avant
cette cette image on a vu une image de
novak djokovic avec le président serbe
aleksandar vucic des deux roues sont
rencontrés le 4 février dernier qui a
sollicité cette audience à ce que c'est
novak djokovic qui a demandé à voir le
président serbe est-ce que celle inverse
qui est le plus à gagner ou à perdre
voulait compris celle inverse
c'est-à-dire novak djokovic et en tant
que no1 mondial a atteint des sommets de
popularité non seulement en serbie mais
dans le monde entier donc il n'était pas
du tout friand de cette rencontre et si
vous voulez c'est pas la première fois
qu'il rencontre gucci tch le président
serbe et parce qu'il n'a pas vraiment ce
besoin là
par exemple chaque année les joueurs de
sting français sont accueillis dans le
club privé de novak djokovic
parce que la fédération tennis serbe est
très faible elle n'a pas les mêmes
structures qu'elle fera son tennis
française donc c'était boutchichi en
beaucoup plus intérêts et si oui c'est
comme dans tous les pays de l'est 1 et
les figures les l'admission et je vous
coupe mais il a des intérêts sur le
point de vue intérieure par rapport à
des enjeux électoraux par exemple ce
qu'il a plus ni daria sur le point de
vue extérieur pour
faire en sorte que la serbie soit
entendu mais sur les deux aspects du vol
intérieur les élections là
comme nous en france un mois plus tôt
donc au début du mois d'avril élections
générales au parlement et la présidence
dont qui les intéresse vraiment à se
montrer défenseur des intérêts sert dans
le monde là en l'occurrence la diaspora
serbe en australie qui sont au moins 400
mines donc c'est un poids électoral
important mais surtout c'est un intérêt
vraiment par rapport au monde entier le
présent vucci tx est déjà élaboré une
politique très forte avec le président
russe poutine avec le président turc
erdogan a de très bons liens avec le
président macron est donc en accueillant
novak djokovic qui est le meilleur
diplomates de la serbie finalement il a
il à cette occasion incroyable vraiment
de récupérer cette icône icône de la
serbie lors de cette entrevue donc le 4
février dernier on les voit là les deux
hommes avaient se serrer la main et
novak djokovic a dit qu'il allait livrer
très prochainement sa version des faits
par rapport aux du cogat et qu'elle
pourrait être cette version alors il y a
plusieurs hypothèses un harnais de leurs
deux hypothèses mais historiens de le
démontrer- ont très vite en fait moi
j'ai fait des recherches comme on est
sollicité et il se trouve que
rappelez-vous par exemple on se demander
pourquoi les bombardements américains
sur le kosovo
dès le lendemain des mois de juin
dick cheney a placé son neveu à la tête
de la principale mine au kosovo et là se
répète exactement une histoire le
gouvernement précédent celui de gucci tx
et c'est pour ça que vous dites là
l'intérêt récupérer djokovic qui était
ouvert libéral dans les années 2000
avait passé un contrat avec rio tinto le
géant mondial ii
finalement du développement des
ressources minières et en serbie
ça pour conséquence de créer ces
derniers mois depuis mois d'octobre et
bien un mouvement populaire contre rio
tinto oh non d'écologie de la défense
des intérêts cologix or il faut savoir
que d'un côté jonah novak djokovic a
soutenu officiellement ce mouvement
écologique de protestation populaire
contre rio tinto qui est une entreprise
à la petite australienne et dont il
vient et en cherchant un peu et bien on
se rend compte que le fameux premier
ministre australien qui a changé les
règles au cours de ce vol aérien entre
l'europe et l'australie sans que l'on
parle de scott morrison scott morrison
scott morrison lui est bien à des
intérêts directs dans rio tinto est ce
qu'il est et preuve de ça alors oui j'ai
les preuves il est actionnaire il fait
pas partie du conseil nistration mille
actionnaires de rio tinto donc ce qui
tendrait à dire que si vous voulez au
delà de la sphère plus ben purement
tennistique et puis de la faire vraiment
politique il y aura une affaire vraiment
géostratégique et un combat comme assez
important entre d'un côté les défenseurs
d'une multinationale et ceux dont
djokovic bien d'autres qui s'opposent à
cette multinationale et ils sont
nombreux il ya plus de dix ans selon vos
dires le joko gates est à la fois une
affaire politique interne
à la serbie avec des élections à venir
pour aleksandar vucic en sait également
qu'il ya des élections qui vont avoir
lieu fédéral en australie au mois de
juin pour scott morrison donc c'est très
politique sur le plan de vue interne et
là vous parlez de géostratégie
également dans tout cela dépasse
largement le cadre du sport et c'est ce
qu'on n'a pas compris nous simples
citoyens bon entre le 13 et 20 jan et le
en tout cas durant le tournoi de tennis
la question maintenant c'est est-ce que
à l'aune de ses nouvelles
et bien informations qui commencent à
être diffusés et bien est ce que par
exemple notre mini des sports nous en
france va accepter que nos à djokovic 12
roland-garros en tous les cas roxana
maracineanu a déclaré inquiet pour
pouvoir jouer un tournoi de sport en
france faudra être vaccinés elle a
changé d'avis rappelez-vous au début
elle a dit non au début de la sphère
djokovic australie et elle a changé de
braquet une semaine après donc vous
savez d'interdire serge et l'esprit date
un français peut amener encore à des
revirements donc
jusqu'où peut aller cette affaire
d'un point de vue diplomatique entre
belgrade et canberra maintenant qu'est
ce qui va se passer diplomatiquement
entre ces deux pays est ce qu'on peut
renouer des liens est ce qu'on peut se
refaire confiance alors c'est une très
bonne question il faut savoir qui est
une diaspora qui est très importante en
australie une diaspora très ancien qui
date de la fin seconde guerre mondiale
on estime entre minimum 300 mille serbes
qui vivent en australie
beaucoup de ces serbes quittent en ce
moment l'australie depuis plusieurs mois
parce que les règles
face au co vides ont été très dures donc
reviennent en serbie et c'est par
rapport à ça qu'il faut comprendre aussi
l'action which il a tout intérêt aussi à
montrer une sorte de soutien djokovic
est donc un une opposition à canberra
parce que lui se place dans une campagne
il ya même un ministre un ministère qui
étonnant le ministère aux terres rurales
qui donne des airs de 1000 euros axa
semble insignifiant 1000 euros
et un lopin de terre pour pouvoir
revenir en service installé d'envoyer il
a tout à gagner le président la serbie
actuellement en tout cas sur un court ou
moyen terme de s'opposer aux australiens
les liens économiques avec l'australie
sont très ténues très faible
il y à ce retour des serbes vers la
serbie donc je pense que pour lui
tactiquement pour le moment il n'y a
qu'à gagner à 7 à cette opposition merci
elle explique rod pour ce développement
cette analyse pour prendre un petit peu
de recul et de hauteur donc sur cette
affaire novak djokovic tout de suite on
continue de parler de la sphère djokovic
mais du côté australien cette fois ci on
va retrouver dans un instant robbie
thompson il est journaliste basé à
sydney il va nous parler donc de ce
joker gates du point de vue de canberra
[Musique]
de retour sur rt france la grande
interview continue pour évoquer le joko
gates on était il ya quelques instants
avec le géopolitologue spécialiste de la
serbie alexis trou d désormais on prend
la direction de sydney pour rejoindre
hobby thompson journaliste australien
pour chanel ten et paramount bonjour
robbie thomson bonjour règle plusieurs
semaines après l'open d'australie
dans quel état d'esprit se font les
australiens après cette affaire je pense
que vu comment ça de voler le reste de
tournoi de l'open d'australie
honnêtement je pense que c'était plutôt
oublié certainement de côté muse de
l'actualité et par rapport à l'actualité
sportif aussi parce que c'était un grand
succès finalement pour ce parti qui a
gagné en
féminines et pour les doubles avec les
special qu'est ce qu'ils ont gagné les
doutes dont les dans un événement très
joyeux très sportif donc finalement il y
avait beaucoup de bruit avant le tournoi
d'un niveau sportif et des autres
au-delà de ça mais mais finalement pour
pour moi ce que je vois c'est que c'est
presque oublié chez nous pourtant il ya
quand même eu des des commentateurs
sportifs qui ont commenté qui ont même
insulté entre guillemets novak djokovic
il pensait qu'il n'était pas à l'antenne
ça fait quand même beaucoup de bruit
c'est même allé jusqu'à jusqu'au plus
haut sommet de l'état absolument il y
avait
des insultes mais des commentaires
comment vous avez certainement discuté
entre le les chefs d'état de la serbie
en australie ça l'est tout en haut
c'était pendant une semaine dix jours
c'était le le sujet
à la télé à la radio dans les bars dans
les bas parce qu on était ouvert
finalement après des très sévères
l'ordre d'armes les cantines mans un
très dur et très sévère donc qui a aussi
joué un rôle très important dans toute
cette histoire mais oui c'était c'était
ça fait beaucoup de bruit mais
franchement c'est au niveau sportif en
tout cas on a passé à autre chose c'est
donc ici
c'est donc retomber un petit peu du côté
de l'australie mais pourtant au début du
mois de février le 4 février exactement
novak djokovic a rencontré son président
le président serbe aleksandar vucic et
il a dit qu'il allait livrer très
prochainement sa version des faits ce
qu'on attend ça du côté de l'australie
est ce qu'on a peur des déclarations à
venir de novak djokovic et quelles
pourraient être ces déclarations selon
vous il ya certainement on a entendu des
entendez des rumeurs comme quoi c'est
sans ses interviews avec le police
frontalière de l'australie le bonheur
bord de police de bordeaux fausse
que c'était un petit peu chaud par
moments que c'est ça s'est mal passé
qu'il était un peu maltraité par ses
policiers
mais après donc il ya certes il peut y
avoir certainement des relations de ce
côté là franchement la plupart des
australiens en
on n'a pas d'avis cerise sur le sundae à
ce niveau là sur ce qui se peut se
passer avec le policier et et novak
djokovic
il ya son cas est devisé l'australie à
un point il y avait les supporteurs de
novak il y avait beaucoup de servir à
beaucoup de serbes qui habite en
australie qui a qui a trouvé ça ce que
c'était mal malhonnête que ce n'est pas
juste que 2 de leur envoyer de ne pas
laisser défendre son titre ici mais il
faut comprendre que les australiens il
ya eu il ya plusieurs aspects le premier
c'est que on a vécu moi j'étais en
france en dehors les confinements mais
il ont vécu ici deux ans très très
compliqué où les frontières ont été
fermées
si vous étiez en france en angleterre
peu importe dans le monde c'était
impossible de retourner en australie
même si vos parents étaient malades vous
avez quelque chose très important vous
avez plus de boulot vous voulez rentrer
en australie c'était pas possible
c'était non les frontières ont été
fermées après ils ont ouvert les
frontières ils ont dit il faut que vous
êtes vacciné et vous êtes australien et
vous pouvez revenez retourner en
australie donc là se dit ouvert un petit
peu moi j'ai retourné en australie en
novembre
il ya beaucoup de monde qui était choqué
quand c'était annoncé que novak sans
vaccin devenir
de levure en fait une sorte de deux
poids deux mesures mais mais du coup on
se dit parce que c'est dans l'avion au
final que l'australie a décidé de
changer les règles puisqu'il avait des
papiers novak djokovic qui lui
permettait d'arriver sur le sur le sol
australien donc comment expliquer les
retournements de situation de la justice
australienne une fois exclu une fois
autorisé de nouveau exclu au final qui a
décidé d'exclure djokovic est ce que
c'est la justice australienne ou est ce
que c'est le premier ministre scott
morrison qui en même temps à des
élections fédérales très importants à
venir au mois de juin
c'est la justice qui a maintenu les
décisions de le police de la frontière
alors ce que j'ai compris et comment on
a compris ça en australie c'est que les
organes anne laure guinée les
organisateurs de l'open d'australie ils
ont dit nous il faut que vous faites çà
çà çà çà çà et nous on s'occupe de votre
fabrique des machines donc votre
exemption de visa pour venir en
australie mais à aucun moment
le gouvernement avait dit c'est bon pour
sept ans valide que novak les autres
vient en australie pour jouer l'open
d'australie donc donc ce que ce que nous
on comprendre c'est que novak était
donné le feu vert par l'open d'australie
mais aucun moment par par le justice par
le police frontières parle par le
gouvernement donc lui il y arriver en
australie en bonbons fois d'avoir rempli
ce que lui pensait à faire mais à aucun
moment les règles avaient changé à aucun
moment c'était pour le gouvernement
s'est dit validé
donc il y avait sept problèmes que il
était déjà là comme beaucoup de réfugiés
qui arrivent en australie des immigrés
et voilà donc il était immédiatement mis
dans ce cas là d'un immigré pas validé
pour venir en australie donc y aller
dans une hôtel avec d'autres réfugiés et
migrants en australie est obligé de
rester là ils pouvaient pas circuler
jusqu'à 100 son cas a été traité par le
temps de voir la justice mais est ce
qu'il y avait des intérêts ce qui a des
intérêts divergents tous les cas au
niveau de cette affaire entre l'état de
victoria où se situe la ville de
melbourne donc l'open d'australie et les
organisateurs de l'open d'australie et
l'état fédéral ne fait vraiment le
gouvernement et scott morrison en
particulier en un terrain on a
l'impression qu'il ya des intérêts
divergents comme quoi
l'open d'australie veut avoir novak
djokovic et le gouvernement ne veut pas
justement pour éviter qu'il y ait cette
décision de deux poids deux mesures
entre vous les citoyens australiens
vous devez être vaccinés mais novak
djokovic puis c'est une star il peut
venir c'est si c'est le cas c'est
ça se comprend ce niveau là parce que le
victoria l'état c'est vrai que on a un
peu moins un indépendant
si vous voulez que qu'aux états unis où
il ya ces 50 états nous on a 7 et ils
sont quand même assez indépendant il
peut avoir des règles par exemple en ce
moment il ya une étape le west knock
dans l'ouest qui est très très grand qui
est toujours ses frontières fermées le
reste l'australie est ouvert avec des
règles différentes par rapport à
isolation de quarantaine par rapport à
l'état mais le ouest restent fermées
donc en supporter sur ce point là
c'était évidemment
une grande attraction pour le victoria
delevoye novak défend son titre très
important pour l'open d'australie et
aussi pour l'état après une fois que
vous avez vu le bruit que ça fait que
les gens qu'ils ont vécu ça pendant deux
ans qu'ils ont et qu'ils ont raté les
funérailles la famille etc et qui
n'aiment pas honte encore australiens 16
les stars les célébrités qui qu'ils ont
des passes droits comme ça ça a fait
beaucoup de bruit évidemment le
gouvernement était obligé de rentrer
dans le dense et met le pied et dit ben
voilà on peut pas faire comme ça il ya
des règles pour tout le monde et ça
passe comme ça donc une décision très
politique de la part du premier ministre
australien scott morrison en vue des
élections fédérales au mois de juin
quelle est sa ça
la popularité à scott morrison le fait
d'avoir adopté un discours anti élites
comme comme celui ci
comment comment est-ce que ça à jouer
comment se positionne l'opposition
également au gouvernement en vue de ces
élections à venir scott morrison est
assez contesté
au niveau de popularité pour l'instant
il sort pas gagnant en juin juillet pour
les élections donc est-ce que c'était
une dernière
essaie de remonter dans les pôles
d'essayer de remonter dans la popularité
des gens
je sais pas mais
franchement je pense pas que ce ce cas
ce sujet de novak djokovic va jouer un
rôle prépondérant dans le
résultat de l'élection fédérale et est
ce que les relations diplomatiques entre
la serbie et l'australie vont s'apaiser
selon vous j'espère on a eu comme j'ai
dit au début il ya beaucoup de serbes
qui vivent en australie on a on a
toujours depuis le 2ème guerre mondiale
accueillis on est un terme d'accueil
pour pour beaucoup de gens après le guen
le deuxième guerre mondiale c'étaient
les grecs les italiens s'étaient suivi
par dans les années 80 80 90 par les
yougoslaves dont les serbes les croates
on a on a beaucoup de monde ici j'espère
qu'il ya forcément un grande histoire
entre le servir l'australie je suis sûr
que
que ça va et pezi évidemment évidemment
c'est une histoire qui est qui est mal
tourné dans une période dans le monde où
c'est très compliqué très compliqué pour
les australiens aussi et donc je suis
sûr que ça va pas durer plus longtemps
que ça dans leurs questions en 2023
robbie thomson est ce que novak djokovic
sera à melbourne pour rejouer l'open
d'australie bah il a encore un an se
faire vacciner et puis on va revoir
merci beaucoup me thompson d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes australien vous vivez en
australie à sydney vous êtes journaliste
de sport notamment à shenzhen et
paramount merci beaucoup pour avoir
analysé le joko gates
on se retrouve très vite sur rt france
vous pouvez revivre cette grande
interview sur le site arte france point
tv by
[Musique]